Gail and Kevin Frazier in Windsor where
they are getting ready for the Royal
Wedding good morning again you too John
we're getting ready good morning to you
guys Noor as you know we made a bet last
week did you know about our bet no no
yes I know about this bag on where the
Prince Harry will shave his beard for
the wedding if he shaves I'll make a
donation to the International Women's
Media Foundation if he doesn't Nora will
give a donation to the honor Grace
Project which honors children in honor
of the little girl one of the little
girls who was killed at Sandy Hook
that's on a gray screen
Kevin Frazier's been digging in for us
on what to expect from Harry so Kevin
what did you find out here's the deal we
went to the streets of London
and hopefully we will find out what will
happen on the wedding day but more
importantly how Harry will show up here
[Music]
in Windsor the opinions of whether
Prince Harry will shave before
Saturday's wedding are as varied as in
the CBS this morning studio and I say
that he will keep his beard for the
wedding you do I think you're gonna
shave it want to make a bed
practically should be worn as uniform
with the beard we'll get to our random
poll of the people in a bit but since
there's so much more to get right at a
royal wedding
we went to Kensington Palace to meet
with etiquette expert Lucy Hume what is
protocol or the proper thing to wear for
the royal wedding okay
well the women have been requested to
wear according to the invitation anyway
formal they wear with a hat so that
would be Leah could be a dress could be
a skirt with a jacket or coat even
trousers women are also requested to
wear stockings closed-toe shoes and
modest heels unless of course your
Victoria Beckham the key thing is not to
attract too much attention away from the
happy couple themselves they say make
sure your outfit isn't too eye-catching
Andrews girls always wear those
interesting hats don't they that was
very much noticed at the last row
wedding their wedding of the Duke and
Duchess of Cambridge it'll be
interesting to see if they were similar
again this time here's the other thing
everybody wants to know will Harry shave
our won't he because Megan doesn't know
him as a man without a beard that's a
very good point I didn't you know the
fact that when they got engaged he had a
beard he's had that for a long time so
we'll have to wait and see another oh
come on give it to me come on while we
wait on the expert let's put that
question to the people beard or no beard
no beard
no good Oh [ __ ] sorry beard beard
I think prantera should keep the beer
no beer
it man what do you think we're gonna see
my prediction he will keep the bed for
the day he's gonna keep the beard I
agree with you a hundred percent Megan
doesn't know him without that beard and
that's not the day to change things up
on your wedding day the man you love he
comes down you're like whoa who is that
I think he's gonna I think he'll roll
with the beer they always say that you
shouldn't try something new on your
wedding day but it'll be interesting to
see what happens we will know tomorrow